yeah I know how to fight I mean whatever
it's like it's like being a mechanic
like you've done it so much that you're
so much you're Fearless though there's
something there's got to be something
really good to feel like you're not
scared to be like somebody's at your
door somebody's in the backyard if
you're like not a traffic stop and goes
hey I'm gonna get a car and kick your
ass to have that kind of relaxed sort of
like no you're not I'd love to have that
pull over have you said that oh my God
you get out yeah of course if you kick
somebody's ass oh yeah quickly quickly
quickly yeah are they surprised like
holy [__] yeah I mean you know most
people don't know how to fight like they
could be there would be tough guys or
they can be you know there's a lot of
buff people but that has nothing to do
with you know the toughest guys I know
don't lift weights really so but you
know I I'm that's not why I love
fighting like I did it I did a docu
series for Netflix called fight world
and because I was in Anthony Bourdain
fanatic right and so I don't bring up
his death oh man devastated yeah yeah
but I took his format and I instead of
fight culture and food culture I I got
into fight culture that's awesome and I
traveled around because I wanted to
understand the what what makes people
want to fight do you know because it
goes against your nature to fight it
really does I mean human beings are
meant to run away you know
um what is it it's I I don't the only
through line that I really found was
most of the countries that I went to and
I went to Israel and Myanmar and and
Thailand and and Brazil most of these
are impoverished
you know nothing to lose nothing to lose
and it's a way to just kind of get out
and that's it becomes part of the
culture much like soccer in many places
you learn to be tough you learn to be
like nothing's gonna affect hey you're
not gonna scare me I live with rats you
know what I mean yeah like I you know
I'm on the precipice of dying every day
yeah you know what do you got what do
you got yeah so those are the guys you
don't want to fight yeah you don't man
because they don't fight for points they
you know like I went to Israel and you
know they're surrounded by no no 23
hostile Nations you know what I mean
they went through a lot Israel and they
still do and and uh you know barring
whatever politics you have I mean these
people you know it's about the dirt
you know so there's nothing you're
really gonna do yeah they've seen it
yeah you know they're it's about
protecting that dirt and their kids yeah
and never again looking down and letting
in so there's that Fearless kind of
thing yeah you know have you lost fights
um street fights
not one-on-one but if there's two or
three guys maybe yeah I've had a couple
of fights where there was with bouncers
and stuff and they you know they got the
the better the better of me because
there was more of them yeah you do some
teeth no you know I gotta tell you I'm a
Grappler and I know how to throw my
hands so I'm I'm okay in both places I'm
I'm a wrestler so I'm I'm good on my
back from Jiu Jitsu and you know I do it
all so I know how to handle myself I you
know I and unless I'm fighting Donald
Cerrone or you know George Saint Pierre
I'm fine but as someone ever just thrown
a punch and you were like oh expect it
like a blind side you know you I
naturally roll like just from from
fighting you know if you throw a punch
me I move my head you're probably gonna
miss me or you're just gonna I'm Gonna
Roll and then you're Adam like a
predator oh boom boom it's fast it's
fast like a couple punches out yeah
we're just one left hook to you you
you're not used to being punched in the
face no no no I don't like yeah yeah
I've been punching this I don't like it
or if I take you to the ground you're
gonna be like a fish out of water you're
gonna be on the ground you're gonna put
your hands up like
you're done as soon as you do that
you're done you know Jujitsu is a scary
thing to know you know but nowadays you
know because of UFC a lot more people
are are pretty you know
are pretty good at it yeah so you never
know who you're gonna you know but
here's the deal if you're a martial
artist if you're a fighter a martial
artist or a fighter certainly a
professional fighter you that's the last
thing you want to do you're not you're
you're trained not to fight exactly you
know what I mean it's it's always the
like the Goombas in New York you know
they take their shirt off somehow and
they want to fight you with no shirt on
like there's always those guys that I'm
like God I just want that guy to get
their ass kicked they do they eventually
do like somebody's gonna get you laid up
have you ever had anybody work you work
with on set you don't have to say the
name obviously but somebody like he
needs to be smacked around a little bit
uh a few times
how do you keep your cool because you're
a tough guy well you don't you don't
like people getting picked on you don't
like yeah you don't like bullies you
don't like you know you just walk over
to him and say hey man when we're done
let's just go outside
nobody just me and you will go outside
like to talk yeah no no no we'll go
outside you know you want to be this way
we'll go outside you've said that oh
what do they say I believe more times
than they've never done it never never
when you say that they're no 99 of the
people out there do not want an
altercation nor do I I mean I don't you
know I don't train to be to fight in the
street like I train because I love it
like I love yeah I love absolutely I
have no I have so much respect for
Fighters
um you know like I see some of these
women who you want to talk about going
against your nature no yeah they are um
and they're so because women don't have
the egos that men have so they learn
like that they're some of these women
are phenomenal Fighters yeah